[Music]
this week's 48 hours investigates the
story of an american couple who adopted
a young girl from across the world and
came to fear her it began more than two
decades ago when the couple brought home
two children from russia they named the
nine-year-old girl cara lee the couple
came to believe carol lee was dangerous
even capable of murder they claimed she
tried to kill her little brother and
they took her right back to russia 48
hours contributor troy roberts covered
the story at the time and tried to keep
track of the young girl over the years
the two recently reconnected and robert
sat down with her to learn her
surprising story
how old were you when you were adopted
i was nine
and that's what i wanted
i want to feel loved and i want the
family
crystal and jesse we agreed not to use
their last name
first arrived in moscow russia in 1997
to adopt a girl they named cara lee and
a boy they named joshua when we finally
learned that we were going to be able to
go over to russia and pick up a little
boy and girl of our own it was just a
tremendous event and we were very
excited
how did the agency describe carolee
a wonderful outgoing intelligent little
girl but they say
carolee started behaving badly
not long after they returned home there
was a coldness in her and an anger and
just a distance she stole all my jewelry
our knives were disappearing and then
she snapped
they say
she tried to kill her baby brother she
had him in her hands and was going to
throw him over the deck she had him yes
yes over the side here yes and i just
started screaming put him down caroly
put him down what are you doing i'm
going to kill him dr brian kennedy was
one of the psychiatrists who saw carol
lee this child i would consider to be a
homicide risk we've had cameras
installed and we've had alarms installed
on her doors
so you plan on taking caroly back to
russia
yes yes i was with them 21 years ago
when they brought carol lee back to
russia
and left her there
you're a strong girl you're a strong
girl
i always wondered what became of her
and last summer we were reunited
and we learned what she says happened on
the deck that day and
about her incredible journey
troy roberts joins us right now troy how
did you finally find out what happened
to cara lee now sabrina
well we connected
on through social media
and
i asked her if she would want to tell me
her version of the events and so i went
to north carolina where she lives now
she's
a beautiful young woman married she has
four children wow and
uh well-adjusted she works at a hospital
and
um
she
it was painful for her to to review her
her life
but uh she says where she's at today
and her mental state
she's very grateful
how did troy how did it affect you
covering the story oh man um you know a
large part of our jobs
are to parachute into people's lives
when they're broken
you ask them
to tell their stories you say thank you
and you leave
and it was so hard for me to leave this
12 year old girl in a lot ward
in
a psychiatric hospital in moscow and i
was haunted uh
by this story
and
surprisingly it led to my own adoption
journey i
later adopted a four-year-old boy from
djibouti africa
he's now 23.
gets on my last nerve
as most kids
but troy i can hear the emotion in your
voice so thank you so much for covering
this and updating us on this story you
can see troy's report what happened to
the perfect child on 48 hours tomorrow
night at 10 9 central right here on cbs
and on the viacom cbs streaming service
paramount plus
we'll be right back